okay
oh hey everybody this is sam uh
from python basics doing our bi-weekly
streams so today we're going to be
looking at tkenter
and building a little t-kenter
calculator
so is anyone
uh familiar with
what a gui is has anybody ever heard
that term
gui so it's
graphical user interface
and all that is is how are we going to
interact with a user and take input
and put it on the screen and have it be
visual so we just aren't uh
using command line things and things
like that
so all right let's go ahead and
just get after it
all right uh
and jan if you have anything that
is getting out of hand because i think
you are
a moderator as well if i recall
i think i hope they gave you access
because i don't see cardinal here
because i think he did it two weeks ago
okay so let's just go ahead and get
after it so one of the
gui modules in with from python
is tkinter and
it is literally just like this
i think one time i heard
uh tktk enter but i know
i know it as tkenter so all right i just
saw a comment about the volume
is is the volume not that great
all right this is the first time
okay volume's okay all right
oh okay jan i thought we gave you
admin we'll we'll talk we'll talk on uh
discord after this i don't see cardinal
yet all right
okay so tkenter let's just get into it
so we bring in t kenter and we know all
the little tricks
well we're going to use some aliasing
because i don't
want to type to a lot
like like normal all right so i do der
and i do tk and here are all of my
functions and methods
that i use
um to get things going and the first the
very first
step is this tk
capital t capital k so let's look and
see
what in the world this does
so i'm going to just we're just going to
walk through it we're going to get a lot
a few few little learning things out of
the way
and then we're going to jump onto the
calculator and
uh you have to forgive me if i sound
um if i mumble a little bit today
i have i had some mouth
some some dental things done and it's
i'm not completely recovered
so well let's not
get ahead of ourselves so let's look at
help
tk capital t capital k
so
all right it's a lowercase k
now look how big this all of this
is so let's bring this over so it's
going to make a
whoa screen so i got some optional
arguments here
but it's going to make a object top
level widget
and all that is is a fancy way to say
i've made an i've made an object
and we can do a tremendous amount of
things with this but this is our
building block
this is our actual window then we can do
things
to that and inside of that window
so tk
now i'm going to show you that you can
get this to work
but this is not best practice right here
this is not best practice to do
i will show you best practice let's
close this down so we can see
so we're actually going to create our
window object this
is i just got it going but it's we're
not in control of it right now
it's just there so now
now we're having a little bit more
control and i have
a now let's look
and tcanter objects begin
to layer very quickly so i want to show
you
now that
now i have an object
that then now has a tremendous amount of
items that we can do
oh yes everybody jan awesome thank you
this is now our 11th video in this
series
so we've done we've done a lot of basics
we've done a little bit of problem
solving we've looked i think the only
thing that i need to add to
today that um we haven't done
is we're going to look at
um the evaluate function that's about
the only thing i don't think we have
touched on
but um yes you can use idle the reason
why
the reason why i use this is
specifically for beginners this
everything that i'm doing
is really based around somebody who has
never
used python so
these are the tools that you get and
everybody can use them i do
i use others but i don't want you i want
you to find something that works for you
but everything that we do here you can
do an idle
you have this script editor which is
fine which gets the job done
and of course then you have the
interpreter shell so
it's it's fine it's a great starting
place and you can do everything here you
don't have to worry about
um importing and environments you don't
have to deal with any of that that's why
we're doing this so okay
now let's find something called
main loop let's see if i can do my
alphabet
very well but the next thing is that we
are controlling this but it's not
really quite controlled let's see
there i didn't want to embarrass myself
anymore
main loop right here this is how we
actually
control and have best practice
where i'm literally controlling
everything and then now i close it okay
so now let's start getting into
some more controls of this window so
i've just assigned
my tk object into a variable when
then i take my win object and i run
my main loop on it so we didn't even
look at that
when dot main loop
but again if you are new here great
we're glad to have you here make sure
you're supporting
free code camp wonderful organization
i've gotten to know quincy and bo
over the past few months and uh their
team is doing some wonderful things
to ensure and i've had my youtube
channel if you're interested in seeing
any of these things down in the
description
below is a link to my channel
everything that i've done on here has
micro videos
over there so if you like long format
great here we are if you get overwhelmed
and you want shorter format you can jump
over there
and i have little micro videos but i
believe
in what uh quincy is wanting to do
and uh that's why i'm spending my time
here and giving you guys some really
good
info best practice and some pretty good
skills so all right
main loop call the main loop tk okay
that's pretty self-explanatory
now now let's look at how to control the
window
because right now python and tkenter
are just doing what they know showing
where what size to be no information
and nothing else
so let's see let's run der
on when see what we get
should be no title
is that something that we can do okay
here we go i can have
a title so let's look and see how this
works
so help when
dot title okay
automatically defaults to none set the
title for this widget
or for our window the term widget is a
term that's been around for
decades it's an indiscriminate way to
describe
an object here's an object
and then i'm sure you've seen it on your
phones now it's pretty
pretty much adopted everywhere
what's up cardinal thanks for joining us
today all right cardinals are admin we
need to make sure cardinal remind me to
uh
let's get jan um admin i thought i sent
that off to free code camp to to beau
um help me remember because i don't want
you getting overwhelmed
but yes we have two awesome uh or we
will have two awesome i don't think
uh yeah it's supposed to be the wrench
okay
yeah so something went wrong but uh all
right glad to have everybody here
uh let's get after it so when
dot title
and what did we learn right here oh and
look at this
we bring in a we pass in a string
calculator
let's see if i spell right get all of my
things
so boom
okay now let's see it automatically
or default it's it's default argument
goes to a certain size so
let's see what other tools because i can
shrink this and here we go
so that's not very handy that this just
comes out and is of a
it's not that if i start putting buttons
here the
so one i at least want to be able to see
calculator
so guess what python and t cantor have
solved this
for us
and there's two ways we can do this
help not win dot
configure
[Music]
all right so now this can take multiple
arguments we're going to look at a
couple of them
so when dot config
ear and
so we got width
300 height
300 so now i'm starting to control the
size
okay so here we are right now now
you can also pass in
a background we're not going to go into
all of them but you have a tremendous
amount
of control over
your window oops i think i spelled
background wrong
and
i got me an n forgot an n
boom there we are so this is
one way to control now i'm going to show
you
another way to control
t-r-y if you're if you've been here a
while you've heard me say that i am not
a speller now
this takes a string for the dimensions
so we're going to pass in
the exact amount and then i'm going to
click over
and i think my kids are right i think i
do need
a third yeah guys
look the comments need to be
uh python related and if we can
have them be just specifically related
to this tutorial
because the mods have been instructed to
um
to just kick you because look we have a
lot of because it
it was um only member chat only
but um had a chat with quincy and we
wanted
as many people to be involved as
possible
um so let this is your warning
i want you if you want to be here to
learn let's learn
but the mods have been instructed to
just kick you all right
so the geometry so if we look right here
okay so we got our 300
great whoopty do okay it's the same
thing i can do it two ways
now what i think is so cool about the
geometry is
that that method is now you can control
where where it appears on the screen
and we use the addition
sign to control
where it shows up so let's see
let's do 200 and
200. zero zeros in the top corner
uh x and y as they move down
so if i make this 500
as you can see it moves over x
y alright so now that we have a little
bit of
a few of those things out of the way now
now let's get into uh
i do want to show you some labels and
then we'll get into the calculator more
but i also want you to understand labels
and buttons
so and because we do need to look at
packing
so let's just do this so to do label
and we are just scratching the surface
of tk
now also
there is and i don't know if it's in
this lesson that i go over
as difference between because there's
there's two um
there's tk and then there's ttk running
in in the uh also in the same library
and one is a smoother rounding edges of
buttons and things and it's just there's
a little bit more there's a little bit
more touch to it so if
you are interested in having it
be a little bit softer then
this this piece of teekenter
is very nice and we'll just go ahead and
look at it so ttk
dot label dot win so
i want a label i want it associated with
this object and then this is the text
that i want this label whoops to display
and we'll just go with the standard
hello world
close this out
all right i forgot a very important part
of this
all right would i leave out ttk
label for tkenter
label dot pack
shoot what am i missing
let me check my notes
all right okay i guess something is i
could not believe that i've misplaced
the notes
on
uh labels so we'll just go ahead and get
into
the calculator i guess i
i could have sworn these are the right
notes okay well i apologize
tktk object when
oh
this is all capital i forgot that
there we go and then
there's not a lot of difference with um
the the labeling but with buttons
they have a little smoother edge to it
so
actually let's look at a button
and i do want to show th this is an
important
lesson here about
uh placement and order
so i want to move this
to show
button when dot
text text argument and we're going to
learn a lot about arguments here
in a little bit all different varieties
of arguments that are already
that are set so i run this i get my
label but my butt
my button didn't show up and it's
because it did not get
packed packaged
all right uh so button
dot pack
so i want to show you i move this
so i just moved button so let's see
all right it didn't move it
is how this is
the order is by how this is packed
so wherever it does not matter the
arguments that you create the variables
the arguments you create and the
variable they're assigned to right
that's what we do with our equal sign if
we have some very very
new individuals here it is the order in
which they are packed
packaged up all right that is probably
the most important thing
that you need to understand
um yeah cardinal just uh i don't want
you having a headache
if uh look guys cardinal is here to
partake and help um and also learn
so if we if you guys yep we are going to
be
getting to grid we're going to we're
going to get there
we're going to get there i'm look
everything i always do
i assume there is someone here who has
no experience with it and i want them to
understand something i want
everybody who's sitting here to never
feel overwhelmed
that's the point of all my videos and
all my streams so there we go
alright so we're packing is very
important
because if you do not do that doesn't
happen
now as someone was chatting about
grid why don't you use grid well we are
i want you to understand that you can
have
a very explicit control and how things
come out all right
so we got 30 i got about 36 minutes so
let's just get after
uh the calculator so this is
i didn't show you guys
this is i got this on the other screen
so we're only going to see
this is going to be our end result we're
going to take button presses
plus 5 boom so the only thing that
we should not know in this example
is the evaluation function i've gone
over everything here
all right so let's get after it so we
have calculator we got some geometry
let's see where we need to be and we're
gonna have
quite a few things to learn so we're
gonna go slow and we're just gonna get
them
all all down
all right let's see
let's get in the right spot and see
where we need to start
but yeah i'm really glad to have
everybody here i really enjoy doing this
uh free code camp is a wonderful
organization and i'm very grateful
that i get to participate and do these
streams
and thank you everybody for showing up
here i know my schedule keeps changing
and i did not want to stop doing these
so we've moved to
every other week because i don't want to
just say no
but i can get it i can get enough stuff
done and carve out
uh an hour every two weeks but it was
getting to the point
where uh it was becoming more
challenging
so all right why don't we get the
buttons
and the layout on the screen and then
because we have
we have a tremendous amount to do and a
lot of arguments so we got a lot of
typing to do
so let's let's just start there
so like like somebody commented earlier
why didn't we use
why don't we use grid well
we are because when
when you have buttons and you're using
coordinates and it becomes a headache
well tkenter and python had
thought about this so why don't we do
columns and span span is um
uh base basically padding
and then columns and rows sorry there we
go
let's get started so we have button
and we're just going to name them
button seven so we're gonna here
let's get this up so we can have a
so we don't have to think about it we
can keep this up over here
all right so we're going to do 7
an 8 9 and a crossed and then we're
going to check it always check it and
then go from there
so button equals
all right tktk button
then where is it going it's going in our
win it's text is going to be seven
now here's we're not gonna do the
commands yet we're gonna do
we're just gonna get it we're just gonna
get it to the screen
so then basically a different type of
packing
button 7
dot grid
and then where do we want this we want
it on row
one and column i hate the word column i
can never spell it
then call the moon column zero
all right and we got lots of typing
and we're not copying because i will
make a mistake
and i'm going to live ttk
button i think when i did this on the
video on my channel
i i edited it out because i made so
many mistakes all right when dot text
dot eight and
button underscore eight
dot grid and we're going to move over so
same row
all right i haven't checked on chat
everybody hanging in there everybody
doing okay
all right it's the same row different
column
all right
all right jan cardinal anything i need
to know about
all right so then over one
all right then button so we got seven
eight nine
just like our keyboard just like this
now i like the phone does anybody ever
notice that it's just upside down five
is always in the middle
i was a weird kid i noticed that when i
was very young
all right so the 9 equals ttk
button button when
text because we're going to have a
dilemma here in a little bit that we're
going to have to solve
underscore nine dot grid
row oops i think i'm changing
something yep rows stay the same
columns change row one
i think i can shrink this and see both
chat and
okay the plus plus 500 plus 200
that is the location those are the
coordinates on the screen x
so to differentiate and this so the
times
is 300 by 300 pixels
then the plus is telling tkenter
i want that is now going to be i'm
differentiating between
um the dimensions the size and the
placement so i wanted it at pixel 500
down
and excuse me 500 over 200 down
that was the plus great great great
question
all right
because look i will also tell you guys
if you have a question
and if you're not sure please please
please ask it
because somebody else has that question
or if it's something you just learned
ask it and some
or if you figured it out while you're
watching it still ask it because
somebody else doesn't have that
information because sometimes when i'll
be
in having discussions i'll ask a
question
even if i know the answer because i know
somebody else
there doesn't know and then i might even
ask it itself because that was one of
the things about um
what um quora and stack flow
post a question you know the answer to
that you just learned and then
and then go from there so all right now
oops i made a boo-boo
these all need to be strings
all right so here's my divisor sign so
i'm moving across
seven eight nine and in my divisor
all right then button underscore d
dot grid then row
1
column we
may start copying i hate it but i don't
i want to get
i want to get through as much as
possible sorry this is my other one
let's run this
see how we do all right
so we're getting close
so now the problem is with this one
we do not need this size we're going to
allow
python to help us with the sizing
all right so that's all we have that's
all we need so boom i turned this off
and i said python go ahead and just size
this
uh to what it need needs to be all right
so we just came through
and we did all these all right let's get
going on
our where'd our second one go
did it kick it out do i think it did
because i'm using the same interpreter
okay so four five six four five
six multiplication
all right help me make sure i don't make
a mistake here everybody
all right so four
we got a lot to cover four
four nope see i already did it five
five six
six and then uh what do i do what do i
do when i
when i say for this one
i think i did m for multiplication
so now we got to get this right so this
is four
this is five
yeah six and multiplication
all right so let's kick that out let's
test oops
grid so now we're all down a row see
we're all down a row columns are the
same we're all down a row
now let's check this out now i've left
out something there's a huge
huge important piece but i want to let's
get this all to the screen and then we
need to learn
about some very important things in
teacanter
all right actually the original versions
of uh youtube uh was
was python and um uh django
if i if i recall my reading
correctly if i remember my python
history
same thing with pinterest if i remember
all right so we got two rows
let's keep going so we're doing we did
very very good
we didn't screw up too bad
uh let's see our notes
actually we need to look at our example
feeling very feeling very nervous about
our
all right so we got one
one two two
three three
then subtraction
so let's get changing all this so 1
2 3
subtraction the subtraction sign all
right
close that save run let's see how we're
doing
all right i have missed something
because what just happened so i have
seven eight nine one
two three i did not change my rows
this is why i hate copying you will
never ever
ever okay i will never
get everything correct on the first go
round
so we got seven eight nine one two three
four
five six seven eight nine so we have
we have seven of the nut we have nine of
the numbers and we have three of the
multiplication
so we have uh we still have a problem
all right run this what are we missing
okay we need a zero we need a decimal
we need a clear sign we need a
um addition sign and then we need an
equal sign so let's let's go let's deal
with
let's deal with our fourth one here and
then we have a problem right
here that we need to deal with we got
two actual pretty big problems
and some issues with the whole screen
right
all right i think we're doing good we
got 23 minutes so now
we got let's see we got 0
0 we're just going to stay with our
little
format dot i guess i could have called
that decimal
but we're going to stick with dot just
just
keep my notes so when i mess something
else up
we'll see then we clear it our clear
oops this is again a perfect example
i just pasted
and i started changing in the wrong spot
one two three
okay let's see yep
okay so zero
zero then
dot
dot but yeah what we're going to be
doing next is we need to
we're going to be able to solve the
entry bar or excuse me
the equal button but our entry
we have an entry bar that has a lot of
things that we can do with and we're
going to need to solve that so now
here's our addition sign and then and
here's
uh oops
one two clear
forgot clear and then yeah
i'm reading the wrong and then a
then we need to deal with our entry
our equal sign in a minute
yes uh up up above if you're not on full
screen you can see
uh playlist click on the playlist and
beau has done a great job
of organizing these all they're in
sequential order
and like uh jan and cardinal were saying
this is the 11th 11th one so all right
let's close this out
let's see what we did nope missed one
more thing
row four
columns are the same just changing our
rows let's see how we did
all right we are getting very very close
so we need we need an entry bar an entry
uh
widget and then we need just one big
button to go across
and this is how we do it
so we go
then we're going to learn about a new
just copy this i hate doing this guys i
just don't want to bore you guys
with everything so our equal sign
all right so then this
is going to be equals
e so this is row five
now instead of column three well here
let's run this
we're gonna have a problem okay
we got our equal sign here but we want
this to run the whole
span so we have our padding right here
this is
as we can see python is handling our
padding we can we can do more
with that if we'd like but we had how
many buttons going across
one two three four so we we were telling
python we have column zero one two three
okay we understand that that's zero
indexing that's four
so here's a new argument column span
and we're going to change this to four
so hey here's a button
here's a row take up four columns
oops
take up four columns and then there's
one more little thing so hey go in the
middle
and then there's a little term forgot
this one
sticky which how far do you want me to
go
and these are directional the compass
directional
north south east and west north south
east and west i love this
this is probably one of the coolest
things that i learned about tkenter i
want you to stretch it
take up four and go out in all
directions
boom now all right
now we got into it shoot i got we got to
keep moving
okay now we got to learn and take on
some
a little bit of uh
we got to get into some housekeeping up
here
okay we need to learn about an entry bar
okay entry
ttk dot capital
and tree and if you've noticed most of
these objects begin
with a capital i had forgotten that
all right so we get win
we get
now when we're going to employ what we
just learned
about so grid now where did i start my
row
i did this kind of on purpose so we
wouldn't have to do anything silly
so this is row 1 for our numbers so now
we're going to do this this needs to be
at the top so this is going to be
row 0 so row
0 column span
one day i promise i will learn how to
spell a
column so column span 4
and our sticky
no i wish i knew another language i did
do something and i hope i didn't offend
everybody it was a while ago over on my
channel but i think the top
seven languages i went
and um uh tried to say them if i say
what if i say thank you in
hindi if i can remem remember correctly
danyavad how'd i do how'd i do with the
accent
um but i wish and actually i've
thought about getting some people that i
know
to translate for me
um was that pretty good
i did do good okay well thank you
all right so sticky north south east and
west
north south east and west i will tell
you a silly thing and i heard my oldest
say it not too long ago
never eat soggy waffles that's the
compass around so you know the direction
it goes in
all right
okay so now we need to handle some
commands here in a bit
a minute to get this
math to do it but it looks like we'll
run a little bit over i have a little
bit of a cushion
but uh okay so let's run this
okay now i'm going to show you a problem
that we have to solve if this drives you
nuts like it does me
to have numbers come out and start over
there
and work their way backwards i hate that
i think it should be over here but it
defaults to go over there but guess what
we have a way to handle this
and we use
the argument
justify and we want i want this
to the right all right let's see what i
did
and then we're going to need to handle
so now
boom boom okay all right
but we don't we don't we got we got
nothing
we got not we don't have anything coming
up right now
so we need we need to start
handling all of these things and the way
that
you do this is you create a function
shoot am i am i in frame then moving
around okay
cool i didn't want to be all out of
frame like this i remember i've seen
some videos
i think a few of my first i was i was
all out of frame and it drove me nuts i
think i'd talk like this
i hated it okay but uh i was moving
stuff around today
but yeah hey guys don't forget to make
sure we're uh buying some uh
free code camp merch uh because they're
doing a lot of great work
okay i digress we gotta get this going
uh here we go so we gotta we gotta start
handling some things
so we need to have a press definition
a function
and this is going to how we this is
going to be how we get
keys keys on the screen
and we need to create a couple a couple
little
uh expression we need this to be an
empty string
of what because we're going to add to it
and
we're going to be moving in and out of
functions so we're going to use the
global keyword
sticky was how
where do you want it to go and i wanted
it to go to all edges i wanted to go to
the top of the
uh row i wanted to go to the bottom of
the row i wanted to go to the right of
the row wanted to go to the left of the
row
so i took this and i literally stretched
it out for my equal sign
and um uh my my entry bar
so i set had it spread in all four
directions north south east and west
all four great question thank you
perfect it will span column in all
directions
boom all right so now
we're going to take in this global
because we're we need to be able to
bring this in from outside the function
and make it available outside it's going
to pass through and through
because it's going to be passed to
another function here very shortly
so our cursor which we'll deal with in
just a second
gets moved in and out
all right then we need to handle
oh and we need to look at text
okay we need to do this too all right we
need to create an
object that is a
string a t t kenter
string object how t kenter handles
strings and this is how it
does it uh text
tk dot string
let me get that out of the way string
var alright
so this is how it grabs information that
you're passing to it
and that is going to be our cursor this
is the equivalent of our cursor
and what information is associated to it
that's what we need to know right now
so now as we press our expression
is going to increment up
by the string of whatever num
we take in now there's another
issue that each time we set we take in
this information
we need to re-assign
i'm setting this object
i'm adjusting it every time through
this text object this object and you
have to each time you have a new one
this is how i want you to think about it
this is how i told one student one time
the reason why you need different
objects is this is this is the
present and this is the box so you could
buy
like you could go to a shelf and you
wanted to buy a bunch of gifts that were
the same
but you wanted to give them to different
people you would grab
all of the same objects but you'd wrap
them in different presents that they
would
do different things that's how you want
to think about this
so alright we got global we got global
so now
here is my press
function but now i need to then link
this ability this command
to each button and
each a button object
has a
argument called command so then i'm
going to link these two together
so whatever command or function
activity i would like this button to do
i use the argument
i use the command argument and link that
function to that command for that button
all right i know this is a lot but we're
going to keep going slow
and then for button presses we're going
to use the lambda
all right then press and this
is seven so that i want a seven to go so
guess what
we're going to copy a bunch of stuff i
hate this so bear with me
did i get that last one okay there we go
so i need to copy this
paste paste
paste paste
paste paste paste and we need to change
a couple
we gotta change a lot but the actual
keys
not the but not the numbers they get
treated a little bit different they get
they get the string
and then we need to talk about the
evaluation function
ooh somebody didn't catch this
all right
0 decimal
[Music]
c and addition so now let's just go
ahead and start here so then this
is the addition sign the addition
function because excuse me the addition
operator because we're going to throw
this into an eval evaluation
we'll deal with this clear in a minute
because we're going to handle this
differently
all right then this is
dot
this is zero
[Music]
thank you for bearing with me guys i
know me typing is just so exciting so
hopefully i am keeping this moving
pretty quickly
all right and star ups wrong
do six
five four
nine eight so
let's try this let's run this and see if
it crashes
okay i've already missed one okay
see what else crashes
okay i've i've tremendously missed a lot
of things
we're probably about to copy
copy something because i hate fixing
oh string bar
decanter it's thrown up on string var
okay let's close that out and see if we
get it
okay
and we are not adjusting that all right
text is not defined let's see where i'm
missing
text dot
ttk see what i'm missing
oh anybody else see it staring
str ring all right
okay so i'm getting
okay all right everybody doing good
all right so now now we need to get this
so we have all the we have a lot of the
things associated but
there's one important factor that
is not done so
there is a text argument so on a button
there's a text argument and if you want
information to be in the button you use
the text argument now
a variable we we've we create variables
to be able to do something to them to
change them right
well same thing in tkenter so now we
have
a text variable
argument because that entry bar
not only will it take in input but it's
going to change if we hit the equal sign
so that's why we use the text variable
argument because it can change
all right let's see how we're doing
okay all right so now but
nothing happens when i hit equal nothing
happens when i hit clear
so now we need to handle the equal sign
and the clear sign so let's do that
right now
let's go ahead and close this out and we
need to look at eval right now
so help
dot eval this is about the only thing
that we've not looked at
so in our world we understand that
this string this is what messed me up
times i get oops
i get six i get six sixes
and if i do this
plus
i get 63 not 9. but if i use the
evaluation
function python understands
that yes this is a string but this is
also an integer
in in the world of ascii
so it understands that i can pass in a
string
of a math operation that then it will
convert it
to that answer
i know that can seem a little odd but
let that sit and because again
python understands that and has been
past those rules
past those rules that this yes it's a
string but this is also a number
that is a string right now and if i then
pass it a
complete um operation it can
it will understand those string
representations as a as a math operation
and then return back the answer all
right
okay we got to keep moving so now we
need
two more functions we need an equal
function
hang on let me get a let me get a drink
guys in a cough drop
all right
okay so we have clear
so we take in our global our expression
then we're going to put the expression
back to zero
because we're clearing it right so we're
resetting it
and then as we do that then we take our
text
our string our string variable our
string var and then
set it back to
expression all right
that's part of it but now we need to do
the equal
global
alright total so we just used our
so this is going to
so let's look so this comes out as an
int
it doesn't like that this is a text so
we got to wrap this
in our eval
our expression
then we do our text dot set
dot total all right does that make sense
i know i've gone through a lot of stuff
here
so this is here so now
now i need to come down here and do my
clear fun or my yeah my clear function
command equals
our clear clear function
and then our equals needs to be our
command
equal all right let's see how we did
all right everything looks good i'm here
2
plus 2 equals 4. clear that
9 times 2 equals 18
clear that let's check and make sure we
can do some decimals
um we're going to do simple math 2.3
plus 0.7 equals 3.0 you could handle
this if you do not want any decimal form
you know how to do that
uh nine clear nine divided by
three oops oh i think we got a problem
nine divided by three yep
our divided sign we missed that
where's our divided okay
boom boom all right close
save run okay let's bring this over here
9 divided by 3 equals 3.0 okay
let's do um oh and then you guys could
add the power you could add a whole
bunch of
other functions over here all right we
haven't done any multiplication yet
two times three is six okay cool all
right guys
as always thank you so so very much for
joining us please make sure you're
hitting that like subscribe notification
bell
buying some uh free code camp merch
hit heading over to my channel uh
subscribing we got a discord going
uh cardinals been doing a fantastic job
over there uh being an admin
but yeah i just absolutely love and i
want to tell you guys thank you for
spending time here i know
time is the one resource we do not have
a lot of
but i truly enjoy doing this thank you
so much for spending
your time with me today i really truly
hope you got something out of it
and as always guys thanks for watching
and we'll see you guys in two weeks
all right thanks again bye guys